they made the chinese rambo
yeah right so let me let me explain this
to you
when i was young i had a poster rambo in
my head
and i had a poster of arnold
schwarzenegger right and these were my
influence that's what made me who i was
today commandos special ops but right
now they made a a chinese
rainbow
look guys if you guys view this he's
holding the chinese flag as he's coming
in on a raid right it's very
propaganda so what i'm saying to you is
this man
that chinese pride
is growing
they have the strongest
they have the strongest present in the
last 50 years china pride is through the
roof right now
look at where we are
we're protesting jokes
outside yeah go back go back to that
article you were on the business and
said articles so here's a chinese
propaganda film about the the defeat of
the us army is set to become the
country's highest grossing film ever
the battle at lake chang jin has made
769 million dollars in uh since release
in china september 30th
in the state funded movie outgunned
chinese troops beat their us foes during
the korean war battle chinese box
china's box office is the biggest in the
world meaning this film is also the
biggest
in the world john cena probably starred
in it yeah he's probably crying
somewhere if you're in china
why wouldn't you do this meaning why
wouldn't you do a rambo why wouldn't you
do a rocky why wouldn't you do that
that's not the debate right the debate
is we did that in the 80s right rocky
versus russia
rocky i mean rambo versus russians in
vietnam we did it and what did it build
it built our culture we built our pride
in our people but what i'm saying the
debate is now is that
china
is doing that so what i'm saying is they
have
you know a a president that's very
effective right now they're taking a
national playbook national pride is
going on so what i'm saying is that
country is growing
in ideology right and it is infectious
throughout
the world because now they're employing
soldiers right they have their first
soldiers i've i read somewhere china has
their first soldiers four deployed now
to hold ground in in certain regions
never done china and russia that can
circle the globe
you saw that the missiles right so these
missiles are so dangerous because
they're subsonic missiles that can
dude
they can hug the terrain of the earth
let me explain to you what that means
it's almost impossible to pick up
radar-wise
right we when we go in on infiltration
we would we would um
we call a map of the earth we'll get low
on the radar and we'll just circ you
know basically follow terrain it's
almost
can't pick us up what they have is this
capability now
subsonic missiles you know what i mean
and china has that
does the american military have that too
i don't you know i can't talk too much
about what the military has but we have
some
but they have some advanced technology
now and they have the technology that
made us who we were
drones
we left it all
there was an episode on rogan where he
had this cia guy mike baker it was like
right literally right after you were on
and this is some of the stuff they were
discussing i don't know if you saw that
we left our weapons in afghanistan and
so now think about china owns
afghanistan because they uh they're
they're working with the taliban now
right they own pakistan there's a road
from china through pakistan to in
afghanistan and now they they have a
direct route into kabul which will open
up the corridor into the middle east
where we have no eyes and ears on
anymore and they're building a supply
chain all the way to the tip of africa
and not not to say to iran with their
nuclear weapons
and in their hate towards americans i
mean they openly said it so if you
enjoyed this little short segment from
the podcast that we did here's another
short segment to watch or if you want to
see the entire podcast click over here
take care everybody bye-bye
[Music]